Для мене «Меотида» — це, взагалі, життя.
У мене немає вихідних, у мене немає свят.
Я «Меотидою» живу.
Так, це бігунка сидить.
А оце що?
— Теж бігунка.
— Ні, бачиш кулики сидять.
Це крижень сидить, бачиш.
Це крижень. Ось вона, бачиш.
Ми з вами знаходимося,
будемо казати, в дикій природі.
І тому побачити, насамперед, ось таких птахів,
які зараз сидять на плавнях —
це дуже рідкісне явище.
Бачите, навіть характерний звук видають ці птахи,
такий «курли-курли»,
тобто це все кулики сидять.
Це всі червонокнижні в нас птахи.
Парк був створений у 2009 році.
Загальна площа парку складає більше 20 тис. гектарів.
На сьогоднішній час, на жаль,
під окупацією знаходиться
більше семи тисяч гектарів акваторії Азовського моря,
і більше трьох тисяч гектарів —
це заповідні ділянки: це Кривокоський лиман.
Тут вивчати дуже і дуже багато,
тут вивчати можна цілодобово.
Найцікавіше, що це території, які ніколи не орались.
Цим степам більше 100 років, розумієте?
Їх ніхто не торкався. Це дійсно цілина.
Коли ми відкрили, взагалі, цю стежку,
навіть місцеві жителі не знали, що взагалі тут є такі красоти,
і можна подивитися на унікальні місця,
на унікальних птахів.
В принципі, начебто ми їх і бачимо кожного дня,
але не знаємо що це таке взагалі,
і що вони занесені до Червоної книги.
Ідучи по нашій стежці,
ми з вами можемо побачити і наших тварин,
і ось наших плазунів,
які знаходяться безпосередньо на цій території.
Тобто тут знаходиться і полоз, і каракут.
Хоча, за декілька років було тільки декілька випадків,
коли вони кусали людину.
Ну, ходімо.
Зараз ми з вами йдемо по дну Азовського моря.
Завдяки цьому, що море вже відійшло,
ось на цих місцях виникли такі лимани.
Завдяки тому, що заборонили полювання,
у нас у декілька разів виросла популяція не тільки птахів,
а взагалі всієї флори та фауни на нашій території.
Сірководневе джерело.
Тут таких свердловин, на території парку,
десь приблизно п'ять.
І, якщо б у нас були дуже гарні інвестори,
які б захотіли би, зацікавились цією територією,
то це дійсно можна було б зробити
бальнеологічну клініку з цілющою водою.
Хочете скуштувати?
Її можна скуштувати.
Правда вона дуже-дуже солона.
Мій батько пропрацював
у парку «Меотида» приблизно 15 років.
Із самого дитинства, поруч з батьком,
я знала ці території.
Коли почались військові дії,
адміністрація парку була на окупованій території,
вся документація була, всі літописи,
всі роботи наукові залишились,
на жаль, на окупованій території.
Через ДНРівські, і через українські блокпости
ми вивозили і техніку, і документи.
На свій страх і ризик,
перевозили і потрапляли під обстріли.
Завдяки чому «Меотида» виплила, я можу
тільки так сказати, це екологічне волонтерство.
Люди нам привозили абсолютно все:
старі комп'ютери, старі ноутбуки,
навіть хтось мікрохвильовку нам передав, обігрівачі.
Люди, які працють у тата — це ентузіасти.
Вони всі захоплюються своєю справою,
тобто вони всі віддані своєму ділу.
Невелика заробітна плата,
відсутня матеріально-технічна база.
Це всі такі складові частини,
які дуже заважають працювати.
Але ми робимо свою роботу.
Це мій рідний дім,
це моя рідна земля, по-перше,
тому що я тут народилась, я тут виросла.
І коли я приїжджаю зі своїми дітьми
на ці території, на яких ми були сьогодні з вами,
коли я бачу їхнє захоплення,
то я розумію, що я роблю правильно,
я роблю правильну справу.
Я хочу розвивати «Меотиду», я хочу,
щоб вона виходила дійсно на європейський рівень,
щоб казали: «Вау, це круто! І в нас цього немає».
Де все забудовано, і не можна
дихати взагалі ніяким повітрям,
то тут ти приїжджаєш, ти тут вдихаєш
морське повітря, вдихаєш ці аромати.
Розкриваєш свої груди на повну,
і взагалі не хочеться звідси їхати.